né en afrique du nord
la petit est âgé de 2 ans elle souffre
d'hydrocéphalie 3 litres d'eau se sont
accumulées dans son cerveau sa maladie
n'a pas été traitée à temps l'an passé à
son arrivée au québec son
neurochirurgien lui pose indre et
internes
on ne le voit pas mais ce train permet
d'évacuer l'eau du cerveau vers
l'estomac mais le mal était fait sous la
pression le cerveau s'est atrophiée
son volume est désormais 80% plus petit
que celui d'un cerveau normal évidemment
les mouvements de l'enfant sont très
limités sa tête est si lourde que si
elle venait à basculer son coût pourrait
se briser le seul vraiment espoir pour
donner sept enfants la chance à une vie
avec une qualité raisonnable
c'est une intervention assez drastiques
pour réduire la taille de son écran la
boîte crânienne de la patiente sera
réduite de 60%
il est impossible de donner une forme
crânienne normal et d'ailleurs si ponote
objectif notre objectif ici c'est de
donner cet enfant là le plus de chances
d'avoir une vie de plus normal possible
déjà le positionnement de l'enfant pose
problème l'équipe constate à quel point
la tête de la petite est lourde
aucun d'auto ce sera une intervention
d'exception pour un cas d'exception
une fois à l'écran exposés on amène
alors ce qui ressemble à un casque
ce guide de coupe est en fait la carte
maîtresse de la reconstruction
chaque pièce est taillé à même le crâne
de l'enfant sur la table d'à côté on
assemble les pièces le crâne prend forme
après quelques heures de découpe le
cerveau est mis à nu le docteur
alexander l amorce alors le drainage du
cerveau la partie risque et de
l'opération est en cours on draine les
ventricules où l'eau s'est accumulée
on y va lentement à raison de quelques
dizaines de milles et litres d'eau par
minute procéder plus rapidement poserait
des risques inutiles
au total seulement la moitié des 3
litres d'eau accumulées ont été drainés
mais pourquoi déjà enlevé 1.596 beaucoup
nous l'inquiétude c'est si on avait trop
nickel d'un coup
aujourd'hui ça va beaucoup beaucoup des
complications
le cerveau a atteint le volume désiré on
y dépose alors la structure osseuse
il aura fallu 210 vis pour solidifier la
nouvelle structure l'enfant aura passé
douze heures dans la salle d'opération
trois semaines plus tard un test
d'imagerie
la nouvelle est rassurante le cerveau de
l'enfant a doublé de volume
aucun doute il est maintenant permis
d'espérer
[Musique]